yeah going back to christmas did you
ever have like
any christmas movies or like stuff that
you'd watch
i know i never got the concept of
christmas movies
you did it in holiday movies i don't
know like my dad is like such a [ __ ]
film
i hate it at the moment he hears the
word christmas movies he's like
get a [ __ ] away from i had really i had
relationships where they would want to
watch
[ __ ] around that time they would just
be obsessed with watching the same
[ __ ] movies and i'm like i don't want
to watch
it i'm i am currently in that
relationship right now oh [ __ ] man
i'm like
you know what disney movies are fine but
can we not watch just disney movies can
we just watch something else oh i'd
rather that than the shitty live action
christmas movies
like it's always it's always they always
have like the same kind of titles it's
always the same theme
of like oh it's a romantic comedy kinda
but it's also wholesome and by the way
the entire soundtrack to the movie
is christmas carol i have fun every
relationship i've been in they're like
yeah i love this christmas movie and
they put it on it's [ __ ] elf it's
always out it's always it's it's
always fun elf is like the christmas
classics i was i was trying it's like
the office
for like white people but on christmas
this is their video i was trying to
convince aki
that die hard is a christmas movie it is
totally she did not believe me she was
like
die hard the [ __ ] yipikaya one i'm
like yes the yipikaya one that is a
christmas man
there there are two things that i know
that i will probably not get on with a
person
that if they say like if they love
disney movies more than like
a healthy amount or if they own a horse
those are the two reasons
there's the two ways i know i'm probably
not gonna get on with them so i'm
slightly
what is it what is it about horse speed
everyone knows whole skills are crazy
right yeah that's right
because they they're gonna love the
horse especially in a relationship with
one they're gonna love the horse
more than they ever love you yeah and
that's just like that's a fact that is
horse girls are just the equivalent of
car dudes you know what i mean
the honda civics in their profile
pictures no offense alexi but
no offense
no but like i don't know i i never at
least with us like we never got like
especially with like halloween movies as
well it's like halloween movies
christmas movies
are there even easter movies is that a
thing they try to make that's not a
genre
there shouldn't be a genre of easter
eggs i don't know
christ passion of the crisis of the
easter movie you know just you know
one time my best mate his dad for his
like 14th birthday got him [ __ ] bruno
on dvd
he had no idea what it was but his joke
was like oh i think you're gay son so
he's bruno
what
here you go why are you gay why are you
again
you you are gay here's bruno he was that
one kid where his parents just didn't
seem to give a [ __ ]
yeah they're like yeah sure you can
watch porn i don't know whatever
who why are you hurting
watching some of the christmas movies
but i do like the feeling of just
getting together and watching a movie
like it doesn't necessarily have to be a
christmas right that's that's that's
what i
like watching like family movies
especially on christmas my parents just
have [ __ ] taste in movies
wait what's the definition of a family
like a rom-com or
i don't know i mean i showed my parents
like wolf children with the family
oh okay that was like cool that was like
a very nice you know it was it was a
nice family
i cannot get my parents to watch
cartoons no no no no no this this was
something i had to like
slowly slip into the idea for years like
this is like this is like inception you
know
for years to be i would feel like yeah
yeah yeah you don't just like
rock up in christmas and be like mom dad
i want to show you some animated titties
no you got you got
you got to like plant the seed to be
like yo there's there's some like like
i could not get my parents to like no
matter what i do they would refuse
yeah my dad was like [ __ ] strict
about his movies because again he's a
[ __ ] film
so he's like the only anime movies that
i will like and enjoy
is akira and wicked city if it doesn't
have anime tits in it i ain't interested
because also i think to people in the uk
especially around my parents age to them
anything animated equals for children
right like we should show them wicked
city i mean i'm sure if i did they
but those are the only three movies it's
like is it violent does it have titties
in it
i'll watch it so there's no way it's
already a christmas movie though is
there no i don't
i don't expect my dad to be like hey son
merry christmas let's watch wicked city
like
i don't think that's yeah i don't know
like i i never got
the idea of holiday movies i just i just
never really
saw the point because because again for
us like christmas was like
a time to like celebrate with like
family like i mean like do you believe
in the you saw
so called like christmas spirit and
everything like that
what do you think do you think i don't
know because like
it's different it's different now like
but the only the only thing that's
different now really is being a youtuber
because like my like my entire life um
up until i became a youtuber christmas
was this like special holiday because it
was a holiday
like especially if you're in like an
office job as well it was the biggest
holiday you got of the year yeah yeah
and so i don't know it was just like it
i feel like i got programmed into
thinking that this was like just a
special holiday
and even if even if i wasn't with family
you know
something like watching watching
christmas anime for me
like watching like some of my favorite
christmas anime like the disappearance
of haruhi
was just like that that's something i
could never get bored of watching yeah
man
christmas day i know you love that i
know you love yourself
like i don't give a [ __ ] about most
christmas movies but give me that
christmas anime man
yeah like i don't know i i never i never
chopped up i never thought
ah i could watch it i could watch anime
i suppose it's weird for you because you
grew up in a country where it's sunny
and christmas you know so every
christmas movie
there's no concept of like grabbing a
blanket and cuddling up on the couch to
watch yeah
yeah because you'd be sweating it's just
always [ __ ] cold in the uk so it's
like all right
yeah for us it's like merry christmas
let's turn on the cricket
that was it for us right i mean i think
that as i get older i think i
i appreciate the idea of it more which
is just spending time with family
especially because
i you know my little brother lives with
my parents and my older brother doesn't
live too far away right
yeah so it's not hard for them to go
visit him but for me it's like because i
haven't seen them in over like a year i
guess when i moved to japan
and originally they were like you're
gonna come back for christmas connor
like the first christmas was like three
months after i moved here like no i just
got here
yeah i'm not coming back [ __ ] that i'll
come next christmas i'm gonna celebrate
christmas with the boys
i'll come next christmas psych that
never happened so yeah i've been seeing
my family in like over a year and a half
now which is
is that weird i don't know no it's weird
i mean it's weird and i'm sure you would
have seen them
oh i would have normally yeah i've
definitely seen them oh yeah yeah we
would not be here right now if
if the regular corona yeah yeah exactly
yeah probably probably would be back but
yeah
that's how it is unfortunately yeah
unfortunately i i guess as i get older
it's made me appreciate you know that
what it
is is it's an excuse to right all right
go and see my family then come on
yeah i don't know like i remember like
like when
as as a kid and leslie as a young adult
i'm just like who gives a [ __ ] about
tradition i'm too cool
who really gives about the sister who
really gives about tradition and all
this stuff
but like great growing older i'm just
like you know there is something a bit
special about keeping family traditions
and
doing something special and like you
know it's it's
the whole christmas spirit thing is like
cheesy and like it's cheesy and [ __ ]
like that but
i will say like doing something special
that you do every year on christmas that
reminds you of
you know how you were as a kid and you
know the stuff that your parents
uh parents like bestowed upon you and
everything it's like there's there's
something special about that yeah
you appreciate i appreciate it more like
there was there was like i really liked
as a kid
didn't get it as a teenager and a young
adult and like more grown older the more
i'm like
yeah you know that that's that's a
special thing yeah i also want to you
know just
keep in touch with my parents i'll see
and just see them as much as i can
because i just thought about i was like
[ __ ] my little kid's gonna be a little
[ __ ] if i if he's raised by me
yeah like he's gonna [ __ ] he's gonna
[ __ ] off the moment he can i better
better instill some values in him to
come back and say hi you know
i'm an my dad you did the same thing
it's like no yeah because because i mean
like as a kid the the highlight of
christmas was the [ __ ] presents right
but as you grow older presents become
like a non-factor nowadays when you can
just when you have a display
all right give me the presents get me a
drink though yeah right now my parents
now they're like what do i get you
connor yeah because you know you you buy
everything you want and i'm like well
i don't know actually yeah i don't know
think of something yeah yeah
it's like money can i say money so now
that it's
not a present so just like a non-factor
you've got to have something to look
forward to for the christmas holidays
that's right that's true yeah
spending time with the family spending
time with the fans spending time with
the boys all the boys
yeah to explain what we did last year in
christmas we just uh stayed up till like
3 a.m watching super monkey ball speed
runs and it was
it was [ __ ] amazing it was good that
was amazing
can we start that tradition
get the family around the world honestly
i could i could i could start that
[ __ ] tradition man it is good man you
don't know the magic of super monkey
ball speed runs until you watch one dude
like especially when you're drunk as
well they're like insane like it just
defies gravity
and like just enjoyment they're really
entertaining
it was super entertaining but we also
watched die hard right before that we
did watch
oh yeah we did we actually did watch oh
we did watch a christmas movie yeah
because
because that was when i was still naive
and thinking like die hard isn't a
christmas movie
and then you guys are like no no trust
us because we're eating the hot pot
right while i played
that's right yeah and then we're like
let's watch a christmas movie die hard
and then we watch something like wow you
know what it's
i stand corrected this is a christmas
movie